une production du studio sfr
[Musique]
nous sans filtre présenté par kiss me le
podcast on parle de convaincre nos
invités date situe presque en temps avec
moi doom planquès me viennent de lancer
leur collection d'hiver c'est plus de 40
nouveaux design disponibles qui vont
vous mettre dans l'ambiance du temps des
fêtes allez voir ce honnêtement sont
vraiment au tpi ça permet de rafraîchir
votre celle là de faire un petit
changement en plus de son un code promo
pour vous autres qui laisse f-15 pour 15
% de rabais sur toutes les communes chez
qu'ils me sauter là dessus cette semaine
donne cette semaine on reçoit le
ministre des finances du québec monsieur
eric girard qui est venu nous parler de
qu'est ce que ça mange en hiver un
ministre des finances c'est que ça fait
c'est quoi ce double qui commenceront
leur fait-on si on le fait on son son
parcours de sa vie de son enfance à ses
études son travail
sa passion pour le sport sa passion pour
les chiffres sont là pour sa passion
pour les maths
toujours intéressant en fait c'est même
important de savoir comment notre agent
gérer parce que c'est notre argent à
nous tous c'est ce goal ou ségolène dans
le fond qui cache un trajet qui féconde
et démystifier plein d'affaires en fait
de la dette du québec et que c'est ce à
quoi ça à quoi ça sert puis pourquoi
quand on lit dette a
justement où est-ce qu'on investit cet
argent là où est ce qu'on a mais comment
on peut mieux gérer tout ce qu on peut
avancer en tant que société dans le
futur c'était vraiment super intéressant
de parler de plans d'angers société jeux
pour tous faire la liste en ce moment
mais c'est un beau tour d'horizon ouais
c'est tout le temps de rencontrer les
personnes derrière les politiciens et
puis là je pense et j'espère bien qu'on
est con on espère vous allez aimer juste
avant de vous laisser écouter son volet
remercier ne commence pas
le pas de gaza cette semaine et présenté
par la compagnie soja et copies sont une
compagnie qui font des bougies et des
produits de bien être un mois vous le
savez j'ai trois soeurs qui sont plus
avec moi et ben mes trois soirs
connaissait déjà la compagnie soja et qu
avant qu'ils aient avant qui
commanditait pas de casque en fait puis
avec notre code promo ils se sont
procuré d'autres produits sont bien
contentes mois depuis que j'ai découvert
ces bougies de leur jeu prend des bains
avec les bougies de soja et qu ils y ont
des odeurs absolument incroyable avec
les fêtes qui s'en viennent y ont des
odeurs festive de sapins et de pain
d'épicés jambes
[Musique]
pour se mettre dans l'esprit des fêtes
rien de mieux que de parts mais son
appart et on dit que les diffuseurs
pardon ici au studio de danse studio
d'un diffuseur / jacques rossât 150 le
monde rentre c'est ça aussi c'est ça qui
se retenir d'autres compagnies sud m'a
québécoise fondée par des femmes ici qui
par malheur vous lasser et 100% naturel
les produits sont vegan sans cruauté
animale donc pas testés sur les animaux
distincts portant le studio et soeurs
chaque commande on plante un arbre plus
des jeux de dix mille arbres qui ont été
plantés et je vous rappelle aussi qui
sont maintenant pignon sur rue depuis le
1er septembre une boutique qui d'un
quartier dix 30 kg va donc pas les humer
les odeurs
avec votre propre mii sur place et un
code promo 600 filtre 20 pour 20% de
rabais sur votre commande alors allez
sur leur site ce genre coup points c'est
à vous serez pas déçus notre site merci
beaucoup oyez
le podcast aujourd'hui et commenté par
par les slips qui font des matches qui
font des oreillers qui font des choses
pour mieux dormir plus le temps des
fêtes arrive et ça va se vendre comme
des petits pains chauds donc attendez
pas la rupture de stock pour changer
votre matelas pour dire adieu ou de leur
musique leurs adieux aux allergies pour
dire adieu pour de bon jour à une
meilleure quelques années et qui est
vraiment pris mode tout à fait avec
leurs mots ce antimicrobiens match d'un
adepte la mousse anti microbiennes parce
que j'étais allergique aux acariens
minutes semaine depuis que je dors sur
les mac la police les ont décuplé en ai
demandé qu près c'est peut-être beaucoup
dire ça veut dire dix fois plus mais se
sont grandement améliorées
on a
grâce à cette commandite en fait on vous
donne un accès privilégié au black
friday d'avant sur tout le monde fait
que vous risquez aucune rupture de stock
pour avoir 1 25 % de rabais c'est
absolument incroyable donc du 16 au 25
novembre
on a un code promo pour vous qui le 25
filtre 25 pour 25 % de rabais
honnêtement c'est le corps du prix que
vous coupez fait sauter la thune
n'attendez pas matelas oreillers et
autres accessoires pour le sommeil merci
police libdeh temps partenaires en
continu du sans-fil poker bonne nuit
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dit
monsieur le ministre bonjour
ça va bien très bien ouais
5h30 levé ce matin
la journée ça va quoi aujourd'hui en
fait cinq heures le lever et le coucher
heures lever à 5h
bureau si un ennemi 7h
fini vers 6 heures c'est de faire voire
une demie du porte parole dans la
journée à tous et deux jours je fais du
sport c'est essentiel fait partie des
clips puis après ça souvent je
retravaille 1h30 soir avec les journées
son nom les journées fait c'est peu dire
car
quelques sports avec le sportif du
tennis course hockey extérieur
juge joie le jupon sur balles
présentement je peux jouer au gaz mais
je suis les saisons fait que si mon
tennis
course hawke extérieur janvier ferry la
saison n'est pas longue à montréal 20
euros qui excellent en course c'est vrai
qu'un mémorial c'est vraiment pas non
parce que je me rappelle à québec ont
joué walk extérieur tellement longtemps
le camionneur mariage j'ai amené en
plein milieu du mois de janvier il ya
comme un floppy le sait moi je dirais le
bon par l'environnement un mois j'ai 55
1 1 1 40-1 on a perdu à peu près 30
proportion de saison donc extérieur à
mon horaire avant on jouait
quand j'étais à mes guides 86 on jouait
du 15 décembre au 15 mars nous c'est
rendu qu'on joue du 1er janvier au 28
février wexler on a perdu un mot sur
tous vos en 40 ans en séducteur paresse
c'est du stock car et puis on y
reviendra est temps qu'on en parle et
possiblement d'innovation tantôt le mais
l'image est forte quand même deux fois
calculer sa semaine à notre sport
national
on a perdu 30 % de sport national
pour ça que maintenant et des glaces et
artificielle à montréal les pour avoir
une belle saison de rock extérieur sa
première sortie chez ses tuteurs corey
haim disait avant qu'on commence que
tout est 5 fois boonen risque alors
qu'ils faisaient partie ta vie à ce
moment là déjà avec moi
dans ma jeunesse on faisait deux jours
bonjour baseball étaient bons joueurs
ont acquis l'hiver puis si tu étais bon
ok tu veux aussi l'été mais c'était à 20
si les cours de cuisine goincourt deux
défenseurs noumou je faisais un cador
qui s'appelait la ligue dans qu'estivale
de sainte foy bon jouet des game pendant
se faisait le jouet de la veine pratique
là par semaine par ce choix des gains
c'est là qu'il est arrivé quelque chose
spécial dans ma vie c'est que j'étais
dans la même équipe que patrick roy a
envoyé son frère à l'école de hockey
puis patrick était un homme plus vieux
que moi qui étais vraiment bon
il venait de gaulle et comme pee wee de
haut puis moi je n'ai de gaulle et mosci
tour ah ouais les corps
appuyé lui il a bien fait de contenu au
quai puis moi j'ai bien fait de venir
[Rires]
le frère de pâtes
apparemment qui était en stage le
meilleur que patrick le maux j'ai joué
avec lui en même temps mes terres site
web et ce bon steak tout un jeu
qui s'appelle sans fin c'était fin ouais
ouais après ça il ya eu des vents forts
qui fait que sa carrière déraillé mais
quand même il ya joué un peu pour les
nourrissons et puis ça a été un moyen
mais un
il reste que c'était toute une aile
ouais moi je veux savoir
comment est ce que on devient ministre
de l'économie les finances de son camp
mais ce qu'on commence c'est quoi le
parcours parce que le tepa cinq fois
jouent au quai qu'est ce qui t'intéresse
quand tu es jeune quand tu es qu en
théorie oui au début début 15 ans
les politiques publiques ou l'économie
ça m'a toujours intéressé mon par
tabanou devoir
puis mai à l'école j'étais bon en maths
puis là j'avais entendu dire j'étais
aussi obtient une fois comme entendent
user qu'eux
un actuaire ça gagner pas mal d'argent
cette fois il ya les cours de maths sont
durs en sciences et en calcul un calcul
du loup matin un médecin devenu j'ai pas
trop moi j'avais quand même fait calculs
trop là j'avais poussé que ça faisait
quelque chose et pas juste une intégrale
je faisais des doubles des tripes fait
que mam en actuariat te faisais parce
que tu avais poussée soit parce que ça
t'intéresse est très bon jeu de bon jeu
même avec le chemin en actuariat
deuxième jour et monsieur qui arrivait
qu'un chat roux blanc directeur du
département il explique que sa fin une
actuelle est que je m'enrichis nous je
parle a pleuré j'ai ma main et je me
suis trompé
pas vrai je vois calculer des primes
d'assurance tout mais ça tient pas
debout fait que là je me suis mis à
réfléchir qu'est ce que je veux faire
pipi pendant une heure je travaille à
patinoire j'ai gardé une coupe de cours
un actuaire you pas trop de succès
pilot g j'ai découvert un programme ça
s'appelait puis les méga lille l'ont la
faire le marketing c'est
à laval il ya pleso économie b ça
voulait dire économique des maths un
méga ça s'appelait john turner economics
je m'envole face aux pilotes étaient
durs le mot j'arrivais de sainte foy le
seul anglais que j'avais devez
comprendre que j'ai fini à 66 ans et il
est maintenant 1986 grantham aiguë puis
le seul anglais que j'avais c'est que
les red sox jouer à québec sur un poste
de burlington d'eaubonne youpi tizi
burlington j'écoutais red sox en anglais
ça c'est las le sol sont axa connaît mon
anglais qui fit la gérante amegee sa
bourse anglophone - mon premier coup
legault je m'en rappellerai toujours le
il s'appelait bah oui morts puis son
anglais était pas meilleur ennemi on se
comprenait pas je comprenais rien
je me prépare à pleurer un copain ou
maman l'essm a écrit des équations table
où
je comprends tout nous on va se parler
en chiffre fait la g 4 3 1 méga
puis
économie finance ce que j'ai poussé je
mets deux là après mon bac le ch travail
le gîte embauché par les bronfman clé
reitman ce simple et rise up corp pour
faire du développement immobilier
mais moi ils mobilisent ça ce n'est pas
quelque chose qui est en demande sur des
tours à bureaux ce fait j'ai travaillé
le 2-1
puis lochte allé les voir et d'écouter
mon chauffeur de maîtrise en économie à
lui qu'un puis j'aimerais rester ici
deux jours par semaine millions d'euros
revient le mjs on va être payé non
seulement de son travail de jonathan
payer trop hockey parce qu'on croit à
l'éducation fait là j'ai fait ma
maîtrise qui tablaient sur quoi
sur le rôle la politique fiscale dans
les cycles économiques ok
le travail du canada ottawa une heure
puis pendant cette année là la banque du
canada c'est fantastique c'est un milieu
professionnel mais semi académique je me
levais le matin je vais prendre des
cours de maths à nu merci d'ottawa gens
venaient travailler le cette année là
j'ai décidé chez le faire un doctorat en
économie mais mon rêve c'était de
travailler en finance qu'après une heure
j'ai été
accepté pour travailler sur le parquet
de la bourse où le pôle parquet de la
bourse mais le trading floor de la
banque nationale
et je suis resté l'eau 24 à banque
nationale puis les 7 dernières années
j'étais le trésorier trésorier des
responsables la gestion du capital dé
l'humidité de l'émission ténor cerveau
financier de la banque mais tu te pas
faire un clic il ya un mur de chine
entre les deux j'ai travaillé leurs 24
ans j'aimais surfaite moi j'étais une
économie spécialiste des marchés
financiers où on prédit un trader tandis
que j'ai au début je t'aime maintenant
de marcher tu montes le cours acheteur
le cours vendeur sur différents marchés
depuis toujours avec mig mes bases
mathématiques puis économique ce que
j'ai appris à mes guides à mon premier
cours pas de statistique microéconomie
c1 maximiser sous contrainte et c'est
sympa si ce qu'on fait et boussole ça
marche leur relation de couple
travaille c'est maximiser ce contrat
maintenant qu'on veut illustrer cela
avec un exemple admettons que 1 milliard
qui fait des
milliards de dollars ça c'est à
contraintes budgétaires pilote tu veux
faire
un projet de transport en commun tu veux
augmenter les soins à domicile
t'aimerais réduire le fardeau fiscal
mais le faux su
choisissent la meilleure combinaison de
ces trois choses là je veut maximiser le
bienfait de la société en respectant le
coup de milliards maximisez avec là
qu'on va faire le plus avec avec une
ressource limitée coin rentiers qui fit
escale le trading c'était aussi quelque
chose que tu faisais dans de ton côté où
c'était vraiment juste quelque chose qui
reste notre travail avant
d'acheter des actions est ce qui te
faisait ce genre de choses là
personnellement donc juste une petite
clarification la banque chase c'est la
banque centrale du congo puis la banque
nationale aussi une des six grandes
banques
banque nationale mais j'ai travaillé
pour la banque mais
jamais je
personnellement parce que je transige
tellement des gros montants aps la
banque que c'était là dessus que toute
ma concentration de mérite et lolë
trilling c'est l'application des
probabilités à des événements
nommément mon équipe me dit eric faut
pas tu parles des cours si on le classe
mais samedi au dessus puis on va te
demander
si l'eau mais c'était la méthode le
chiffres et statistiques sur l'emploi
carhaisienne vont sortir à 8h30 une fois
par mois le chiffre le plus important
de tous le chiffre qui influencent de
plus les marchés financiers au monde
sait les statistiques mensuelles sur
l'emploi aux etats unis une fois par
mois c'est vendredi cette semaine or les
chiffres canadiens la même journée ok
c'est que maintenant que les économistes
anticipent qui vont se créer 600 mille
emplois aux etats-unis au mois de
septembre
fait clos les marchés anticipent 600
milles sur ses cannes la valeur espérer
la moyenne de ce que le monde pense
qu'il va se créer d'emplois en septembre
2001 fait le toi tu peux penser que sans
écrit cinq cent mille huit cent mille
neuf cent mille ou 200 milles
dépendamment de ce que tu penses tu dis
il ya cinq ans mettant tu dis 60% de
chances que le chef soit plus élevé 40 %
de chances que le chef le plus beau donc
tu veux te positionner pour que si le
chiffre sont plus forts avec 60% de
probabilités sont faire de l'argent mais
s'il suffit plus beau le dessus je me
rappelle enfin qu'il ya avant le chiffre
moi j'ai toute la semaine j'ai analysé
le marché de l'emploi j'ai mis mes
probable type sur la cinq minutes avant
le chiffre mois le ch comme je suis la
personne la plus anxieuse de performance
je suis dans le parc puis je fais des
tours dans le parc que j'ai c'est de
ralentir ma respiration logements soit
le chiffre
le site a raison ça marche le temps
c'est de l'argent si tu attends pas ce
qu'il faut que tu fasses s'écroule tout
à ce qu avec 60% de probabilités se
fasse par exemple pour la banque 2
millions 40% probable titre perdre un
million infotel structure était et
risque d'une façon non linéaire pour que
tes higuain soit non seulement plus
probable que des pertes mais qui soit
plus élevé avec ses soldats job d'un
trait de scie de faire les guest le plus
éduqué possible sur l'emploi ici de
faire tes devoirs et tie-2 te
positionner
puisqu'il plusieurs c'est quand tu as
raison mais le marché réagit pas comme
s'ils pensaient que le chef est plus
fort mais il se pose pas ce que tu avais
prévu selon fo
imagine qu'au fil du temps etc il ya des
personnes qui reviennent ya des choses
qui qui qui
permettent de mieux évaluer sa de mieux
d'un moyeu combrand il ya des pays et
des parents j'avais raison comme lily on
appelle cela les séries chronologiques
si les données dans le temps sont auto
corrélés ça veut dire que par exemple si
l'inflation du mois de septembre est
plus élevée la probabilité que octobre
soit plus élevé est forte - parce que
les chiffres ont tendance à se il ya des
tendances j'attends ça suivre puis à
d'autres séries chronologiques d'autres
un que ces autos correcteurs un chiffre
élevé suivi d'un chef aime le foot faut
que tu apprennes à internaliser savoir
s'est tu est-ce que ça c'est une
variable qui est otokoré les housses une
variable qui retour vers la moyenne ou
jalili les statistiques ont des
personnalités c'est
ça l'amour des
[Rires]
sites qu'est-ce-qui qu'est ce qui
explique le saut en politique à partir
d'olonne ok ben j'ai toujours voulu
faire ce bien je pense secondaire iv
j'ai écouté le discours du budget
lui même convié jean merckaert écouté le
discours toi j même déjà manqué des
couilles
genou après celle où filent au chapeau
s'est couvert
j'ai marqué des cobras et indice kospi
justement qui découpe regarde in game
n'a aucun
intérêt j'ai toujours voulu faire ça et
puis en 2015 j'ai essayé j'ai perdu la
banque m'avait donné un congé civique
alors je suis retourné j'ai travaillé
jusqu'en 2018 toujours dans dix ans
j'aimerais seul le faso que la prochaine
fois j'aimerais se gagner c'est le fan
de participer mais c'est encore mieux de
granit et faites-la à 2018 monsieur le
premier ministre monsieur vous cherchez
un ministre des finances je pense qu'il
considérait diverses personnes pour se
rencontrer et trois quatre fois puis on
partageait la même passion l'économie
l'éducation
il m'a empêché d'aller chez eux j'avais
une petite fille c'est l'économie
l'éducation
[Rires]
les piles éducation sa saison ont vu
plus d'accès on veut plus de jarrier
acceptons le plus de diplômés
fait qu'on s'entendait là dessus puis il
m'a fait confiance puis ça fait 3 1 puis
on travaille bien ensemble puis
j'apprécie plus content je m'enquiers
puis j'imagine que justement c'était
tout le temps pas en arrière de la tête
ce soit en politique le sait quelque
chose qui servirent mettant le bien
commun c'est quelque chose qui est qui
c'est le service public puis est-ce que
sk la banque c'était quelque chose qui
qui manquait est quelqu'un est ce qu'il
y avait un petit quelque chose qui était
à j'aimerais sauf faire plus ou servir
plus où tu avais quand même ce test sans
chrono demain d'abord faut dire que la
banque ok alors son siège social à
montréal puis le18 dynamique foyer
fiscal une contribution ligne rémy
québécoise peas et si
il ya juste une grande banque au québec
les autres sont à toronto fait que sow
d'avoir un siège social un centre
d'édition québec une contribution à la
société mais c'est ce que c'est un pur
robin des bois si tu fais beaucoup
d'argent fait que ça te permet de faire
des dons
puis bon j'étais à sainte-justine puis
j'étais sans crainte sommet ces lots
je travaille six jours par semaine
depuis trois ans un pour le service
public c'est mieux comme contribution
que quatre espèces est-ce que ça c'est
plus gratifiant pour toi ou est ce que
ben c'est vrai que
je le fais au bon moment de ma carrière
mais il en fait son plus vieux parce que
si tu sais la bourde et enfin politique
journée comme la journée que d'énumérer
un
podcast pour tous
beaucoup
herriot lyon - besoin de sa première
chose parce que moi j'ai jeté mes
enfants mais ça l'est
puis j'ai l'expert gg l'éducation j'ai
une maîtrise en économie mais j'ai
l'expérience j'ai travaillé un an banque
centrale 24 ans gérer la trésorerie de
la banque j'ai vu des enjeux de
gouvernance
j'ai survécu la crise asiatique lalala
11 septembre 2001
la grande récession ont fait que j'ai
j'ai des cicatrices j'étais officier de
l'expérience j'ai l'éducation j'ai
l'expérience fait que je suis prêt puis
si j'avais fait avant j'aurais témoin et
prie et parlant de crise le temps qu'a
voir rentrer en 7ème le
devient ministre des finances puis pas
longtemps après il ya une crise est là
la pandémie n'écrit santa quoi
[Rires]
j'imagine que ça bougeait un peu les
plans ou les aspirations ça avec un
dépôt du premier budget jeudi moi je
vois ça pour le québec
sort rapidement
ça s'effondre un peu quand même
je dirais d'abord la crise la canca une
crise c'est vraiment important d'être
concentré oui et si la crise est job
tout le monde d'abord
c'est extrêmement difficile en santé
mais moi je suis pas dans la cellule de
crise santé ça c'est le premier ministre
la ministre madame et cannes puis madame
blais puis monsieur car demain puis
monsieur à roue d'or nous on est dans la
cellule de crise économique - avec
d'autres le mini économie messieurs fisc
et ben monsieur du bs malo et au trésor
monsieur bull et puis là lol important
durant crise et d'être concentré puis
d'être calme parce que tout le monde
s'énerve et que j'ai deux téléphones les
deux sonos min 1 il ya des gens qui me
demandent des choses on peut te faire
voir chant 10 millions pour demain
mais ça c'est justement une des
questions que je posais c'est la
pression doit venir de partout dans les
affaires comme ça parce que c'est vous
qui décidez en bout de ligne tout en
présentant un peu le cas d'un oui mais
de l'eau l'avantagent avoir vécu
d'autres crises parce que c'est là que
tu te rends compte d'une troupe de
choses c'est que premièrement pour que
je sois calme quand tout le monde
s'énerve et le moment où vous ne
souhaite plus calme c'est quand tout le
monde était nerveux ensuite tout le
monde dit que t'as pas de temps qu'il
faut décider sur locke mais si tu donnes
un peu de thym
et une amende de 110 millions demain la
réponse est non si tu es capable
d'attendre jusqu'à lundi on va analyser
le dossier on va réveiller pour réciter
des puis peut-être qu'on va te donner
618 peut-être qu'on va donner 65 ans
va-t-elle donner différemment on va
s'assurer que ce qu'on fait à court
terme et cohérent que ce qu'on veut
faire à long terme et à long terme ont
vu une société plus instruite
puis on veut une société plus riches
parce nous donne des moyens pour lutter
contre les changements climatiques
santé éducation fait ce qu'on fait dans
l'urgence ou garder un oeil
sur le long terme je comprends mais
c'est un équilibre qui dure à trouver
quand même pas ce qu'est l'urgence et
pis c'est pour ça que si tu prends
mais tu entends d'ici on apprendra en 24
heures je prends toujours là mais tu
derniers trous faut plus de tentes
avaient fait que l'os et moi j'essayais
de ralentir un peu tout le monde et
on est dans l'urgence il ya urgence
puis c'est un peu différente la santé
parce que là scientiste comme moyens
limités on a des problèmes s'ils me
demandent 110 millions des masques on
donne sur un million c'est sûr mais même
lot
placement là j'étais avec mon collègue
christian du big men m et lisa santé
même l'on prenait le temps de bien
analyser la demande est ce que je
comptais pas c'était
parce qu'on parce qu'on a des ressources
limitées ouais
c'est commun
c'est comme un homme qui a essayé de
faire
d'utiliser toutes les ressources
limitées comme tu disais tout à l'heure
dans le fond le tien menace d'une
situation de crise comme ça c'est mon
truc c'est de sa part est vraiment plus
claire
tout des causes state moi j'ai l'image
le titre qu'il ya des points si le futur
trash les sens
l'anglais disconnect de dentiste mes
dessins à numéros mais c'est so foot
face les liens
pilote eut voile ensemble après avoir
fait les
mêmes études justement la gestion de
l'argent dans une crise comme ça ça
n'est visiblement éducation éthiques et
philosophiques à se poser deux harpes
aux idées c'est quoi qu l'échelle des
priorités aussi le tt ii où est-ce qu'on
investisse d'argent le pitti je me
souviens au début
dit qu'il est compromis confinement est
arrivé il y avait quand même des bottes
et puis avait la position des fois
seulement qu'on finit le plus tu es pour
protéger sauver les vies pitt avait
aussi un discours de ben non il faut que
l'économie continue parce que ce sera 10
des répercussions safer va créer des
dommages collatéraux de ce qui en bout
de ligne tout le monde en raison à leur
manière selon leur échelle des prix
finalement comment qu'on ne t'a menti
vous votre job c'est de créer un québec
qui qui prospère que l'économie va bien
bah après ceux aussi y cette urgence le
comment qu'on l'apprend décision mais
d'abord la priorité c'est la santé et
parce qu'il ya pas de croissance
économique
si pour la sécurité c'est déjà en partie
ce c'était clair on a compris sow le
premier ministre j'y vis tu des fois les
mesures de confinement la cellule
économique on l'apprenait
après qualifiante et prism il le fallait
aller vite parce qu'on sait que le
nombre de coptes tu vois aujourd'hui
c'est l'état de l'épidémie est trop
semaine
donc si je pense qu'avec ce que tu vois
faut que tu confirmes ça veut dire que y
est engagée
ensuite moi j'aime quand on dure et les
gens pour ces titres
l'autre chose que moi je disais souvent
le monde y est c'est urgent tu peux tu
nous a aidés là moi je disais est ce
qu'ils ont perdu leur entreprise où
est-ce qu'ils vont perdre à l'entreprise
pièces qui ont perdu leur emploi parce
que si tu me dis là ça va pas bien mais
ventes ont baissé de 38% la main et que
tu vas attendre un peu parce que je sais
c'est 100% la brise puis fait que si ce
sera un test que je faisais le joueur
souhaite appel
il est quelqu'un qui prône stadium puis
quelqu'un qui a perdu son entreprise ou
qui vont la perdre déjà l'os sauce
turgeon
ensuite mes ventes sont en baisse de 22%
écoute on est confiné c'est ce qu'on a
compris après au début de
l'économiste arrêter la machine ou bleu
je regarde les secteurs économiques
pilote je calcule au qui lui ferme et
lui pour fermer lui ferme et plus je me
dis ok je pense que 40% de l'économie
fermé
mais ce que j'avais pas compris
c'est que
40% de l'économie est fermé mais pas 100
%
faites-le finalement c'est 23 % de
l'économie qui était fermée à tarif
23 % des cas limités fermé ce qui est
déjà un chiffre complètement différent
pilot moi je pensais que ça allait
coûter comme 15 milliards on avait fait
15 milliards de déficit on a les clés
budgétaire de pandémie il ya une
pandémie il ya une récession mondiale la
pire récession depuis la deuxième guerre
mondiale selon les milieux en sorte puis
lors il va avoir dix des finances
publiques je pensais que ça allait lui
piquer comme 15 millions les faits sont
là on a dit on va dire ce aux québécois
c'est à peu près six semaines que la
pandémie commence et on sent enfin une
entrevue
points 40% moins 15 millions mais là on
aura fini nos calculs puis on sait
maintenant que c'était 23 pour simple
quelqu'un c'était 10
mais ce qui est intéressant lorsqu'on
est sorti le gouvernement du québec le
ministère des finances
le ministre des finances fédéral puis la
banque du canada il voulait pas le dire
il voulait pas dire combien ça allait
globalement c'est qu'on vise à affirmer
ayé trop tôt lorena crise l'argent la
partie aux québécois faux l'entrée d'un
rôle de le fit ya donc là ce moment
c'est grosso modo 10 milliards de
déficit et 2 par rapport à ce qu'on a ce
qui se serait passé s'il ya peu de temps
et mis dix premières années parce qu'il
a mal géré le match qu'on savait pas à
ce moment là ça allait durer pendant le
culot et il y en avait qui il disait
je savais que tu partes sur une autre
idée tu peux juste pour synthétiser
lundi posé la question il faut prendre
des décisions éthiques parfois mais
comme comme comme on vient de
l'expliquer finalement toutes les
décisions et ils peuvent calculer le
dessus on un shift météo est ce que
l'argent va ben si l'audience si ferme
où ils perdent leur job c'est beaucoup
plus important que quelqu'un qui a eu 31
% de diminution et dont les décisions
sont pas vraiment et ils sont calculés
je pense que éthique c'est le bon mot en
ce sens que l'éthique c'est non
négociable on est on est toujours dans
le respect des lois puis
on est conforme aux meilleures pratiques
et puis sur la transparence des finances
publiques mais il ya des choix mon rôle
ce qu'ont refusé l'idée au maximus
contrats qui pourront pas aider tout le
monde
ml c'est que c'est beaucoup plus dur en
tourisme
que celui qui vint par exemple
des ordinateurs portables parce que ce
soit la demande augmente
puis le tour et je suis complètement
fermée comme et on vous auriez une
business de croisière organisée les
crocs là et ça a été vraiment dur les
derniers tubes d'un projet qu'on avait
québec c'est important les croisières
ils laissèrent été complètement mais est
la question que j'ai posée c'était les
chiffres de 10 milliards ça nous
apparaît pour moi puis pour ph comme
disait un énorme chiffre mais ce que 10
milliards en termes de finances du
québec c'est catastrophique où ça ce
genre à bateaux mais oui chercheurs puis
l'économie voire bien puis les finances
publiques des sols et davin laisser ce
qui est important pour quoi faut avoir
des finances publiques solides
c'est pour pouvoir
agir à long terme lutter contre les
changements climatiques assurer le
financement de l'éducation de la santé
réduire le fardeau fiscal faire face au
vieillissement de la population mais
aussi faire face à des crises ils vont
d'abord donc récession c'est pour ça que
quand ça va bien il faut que tu un
milliard da situation fiscale
parce que parce que là ça va bien moi
ils parlent de récession quelque chose
là ça va moins bien que c'est important
d'avoir un bon bilan d'abord une bonne
santé financière pour pouvoir faire face
aux intempéries fait que le 10 milliards
donner une idée
ce style est une espèce de la crise que
personne à parler mais un jour quelqu'un
écrire un chapitre là dessus aussi le
financement c'est pour donner des
milliards il faut que tu disais
qu'ils nous le québec on aime un
programme de financement de 15 milliards
ça veut dire qu'on en a
présidé le on est à 200 milliards de
dette l'échéance moyen de la dette s'est
11 ans avec on finance à peu près 20
milliards par année chaque année 200
millions onu 20 milliards à refinancer
mais quand je dis on passe de 0 à moins
qu'un ça faisait que mon programme de
financement vient passer de 20 milliards
35 ans 36 heures
l'autre je transpire un pull fait le
show
était pieds humides les mains moites
c'est robin pilote eut dit ben on voyait
mettre plus
mais les marchés sont fermés parce qu'il
ya une pandémie une pandémie c'est
mondiale le tout le monde ses programmes
de financement auront explosé en hausse
puis donc tout le monde a besoin de plus
d'argent puis le les marchés ont la
confiance d'un intangibles comme
important les marchés ont plus confiance
les marchés sont fermés et toi ton
programme de financement viennent
doubler pilotes ce que tu as des besoins
fait le faux cils up faut que tu dises
au qu'il faut être calme parce que tu
veux pas dire on a besoin de financement
parce que le solide un seuil important
site d'info tu veux faire du financement
quand on a pas besoin
une ambition de forage fait le marché
s'est calmé un peu
puis le chine ou au ministère des
finances on a dix experts en financement
parce que le québec on a beaucoup de
dettes fait qu'on a développé une
expertise dans la gestion
faite là le marché se calme un peu les
banques centrales sont intervenues les
gouvernements ont dit les choses
rassurantes
ppi lors le québec on a été les premiers
à faire une émission en europe
je pense et on est mis comme 2 milliards
d'euros 3 millions aux canadiens la
hausse en fin d'émission a
promis aux moins de 35 ans 9,3 en 35 à
faire un an j'avais à peu près
de 120 la trop je pense qu'un marché us
ouvrent enfin notez mission demi-heure
ios marché canadien de le rapidement ça
dure et peut-être une semaine on n'avait
pas accès au marché pression de l'action
marcher tranquillement mais donc dans le
pire de la crise c'est à pas trop
clairement ce qu'on a à se financer
ouais on gardait confiance donc après on
a des réserves on avait des réserves on
aurait pu poste financé pendant six mois
au point que parce qu'on avait des
raisons
même en années tu veux garder une
position de force tu veux rester en
position de force parce que moi je dis
au gré de la santé à ce moment le
système américain tout ce que tu as
besoin de te le donner la portion faut
que je gagne ouais
c'est un aspect de la crise les
programmes de financement qui est moins
connu ouais
justement moi
la gestion des deee tout ce concept là
de dette on dirait pour moi ma paraît
tellement abstrait abstrait là si on
dirait que j'ai on dirait qu est-ce qui
ce qu'est ce que c'est alors
concrètement
qu'est-ce que ça amène concrètement nos
vies la berd puis pourquoi c'est si
important de revenir à zéro puis
pourquoi est-ce que tu l'on se rappelle
de de l'austérité de kinés libéraux de
philippe couillard puis pourquoi est ce
que c'est cette obsession la de gérer la
dette puis est ce que c'est si important
est ce que c'est on peut la financer sur
plus longtemps c'est que comment ça
fonctionne que qu'est-ce que celle là
comme répercussion pour nous autres
hockey qu'on est la pire on en entend
parler d'être on n'a pas parlé de date
mais au final on fait une dette envers
qui de temps vers quoi répond à une
question la réponse à votre question
c'est que le premier poste budgétaire du
québec sq la santé à peu près 40 euros
pour sein de nos ressources le québec
c'est 125 milliards de revenus puis
normalement lorsqu'on était en équilibre
sur 25 milliard de dépenses annuelles
gouin grosso modo hockey mais là on
n'est pas lui qui les monos réussite
mais c'est sur l'ordre de grandeur qui
du char 25 milliard de revenus 9 25
milliards qui viennent générales
s'améliorent
lire ce qu'on appelle les revenus
autonomes mais pour les corporations
l'impoli parce qu'il attaque sera
fait que premier poste budgétaire la
santé 43 pour sa deuxième poste
budgétaire éducation et enseignement
supérieur intro pour sa 15 et 8
suspension parce que maintenant c'est
2000 ça c'est paris mais ça fait du sens
c'est quoi les missions de l'état santé
éducation
sécurité publique troisième poste
budgétaire
service de la dette c'est pour ça que
c'est important c'est parce que les la
dette la chambre des déficits cumulés du
passé plus qu'on emprunte pour faire des
investissements à long terme comme des
hôpitaux des routes des universités
il ya eu tout un coût d'intérêt il ya un
coût d'emprunt là-dessus fait si j'ai
200 milliards de dettes à
4 % par année de tout moyen mais j'ai un
service d'aidé
de 8 milliards d'années ça c'est mon
troisième poste budgétaire ça veut dire
qu'un comines pour sa 1 4% de tous
moyens métro et demi non mais je dois le
troisième poste budgétaire combien de %
du budget
à
peu près 7 8% qui
fête ses 7 8% du budget qui baisse et a
dit qu'elle avait un court ballet
maintenant mon service de dette cette
année 6 8 millions ouais
je suis en intérêts sur la dette cette
année l'argent que je mène à des jeux
les peuples mais tarde car je ne le
parle c'est se sait sur le sait cabos
mais un terrible je te parle pas de ces
pas comme une maison une maison est un
remboursement de capital [ __ ] paiement
d'intérêts le mou je te parle juste du
paiement des intérêts c'est une perte
sèche un écueil en biais
sur soi rien ils n'étaient pas des
petits poneys avec il n'y a pas assez
pour meyer les écoles il n'y a pas plus
d'infirmières mais tant qu'on mette en
cause pour ça il faut contrôler la
teneur aulas doit qui sera là on la doit
aux investisseurs s'est principalement
des caisses de retraite qui fait quand
on une partie qu'on se doit nous mêmes
nos photos nos fonds de pension en haut
une partie qu'on doit à dix étrangers
lorsqu'on aimé
dollars américains de l'heure en euros
on lui doit les etr on la doit des
étrangers il ya des gens plus déranger
nos mamans plus que tout dépend du fait
qu'on peut dire aussi que les jeunes la
doivent au plus vieux ok parce que c'est
pour ça qu'on dit qu'on a un fond les
générations pour rembourser la dette
parce que la dette c'est un pope les
générations futures parce que les
ressources que je met sa dette je les ai
pas pour investir en santé en éducation
lutter contre les changements
climatiques faire face au vieillissement
de la population
fait que ces signes les intéressent la
dette une perte sèche puis le fait qu'on
a une si grosse dette ci dessus une
série de mauvaises décisions que année
là où c'est inévitable d'avoir une dette
peas est normal alors bon
c'est une c'est ce qu'il faut comprendre
l'émoi lorsqu'on pense au québec
économique moche j'ai deux chiffres nous
sommes 23 % de la population indienne
on a déjà été 25 mai on reçoit moins
d'immigration en proportion de notre pro
on est 23 % on est 20 % de l'économie ça
veut dire que on y est on est moins
performant que la moyenne canadienne
depuis longtemps en fait depuis les
années 50 on a pris un retard parce que
aussi on peut voir ce aussi comme le
déclin de montréal par rapport à temps
au tour jusqu'avant montréal se plaît
pourtant que toronto pour rien que la
banque de montréal à s'appelle banque de
montréal la banque royale son siège
social à montréal parce qu'un moyen des
plus importants que toro tous mes sauts
dans le temps ce sas et modifier le
l'économie devenue plus forte en ontario
dans l'ouest avec l'énergie la
colombie-britannique parce que le
le québec puis les
l'ontario est centré sur les etats-unis
le commerce est que les états unis
l'europe aussi à cause de l' empire
britannique
la france
vieillit pour l'asie l'accord
britannique choisie laisse pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui
l'asie plus dynamiques laurent puis
c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui la province
à peyrusse chacun britannique
avec le new 23% la population 20 %
d'économies c'est des retards qui ont
été accumulées
peut-être 60 un mélo nous d'un
gouvernement on veut fermer cette école
on avait une écarts de richesse de 16%
avec l'ontario s'est rendu un peu moins
13 puis là on travaille on a eu plein
vision à long terme pour fermer l'écart
de richesse avec les autres provinces
canadiennes we will smith et c'est pas
parce que c'est mieux d'être en moyenne
canadienne
13% bol c'est pour se donner les moyens
pour réduire le fardeau fiscal du quai
conti changement climatique puis si on
reprend
le taux
qui part annuellement pour les intérêts
de la dette qu'on parlait peut-être de 8
milliards
à titre indicatif quel genre de projet
auquel genre de choses on peut faire
avec 8 milliards m'est tombé
dessus comme étant plus essayer de viser
le nombre de grands enfants ok 1
mais par exemple présentement un
beaucoup de gens qui parlent des soins
des messieurs qui on devrait faire plus
de soin de me suis dit nous on a rajouté
un peu à peu près 400 millions par année
soit un missile vont ajouter 10 euros
puis des travailleurs mais la demande
est plus grande plus concret je pense
qu'on met actuellement 1.5 millions par
année un soin de monsieur qu'est
fait que c'est considérable ben oui
comme je dis c'est notre troisième poste
sénat ces visites plus importants que la
sécurité publique et que ces prix
important que l'environnement c'est plus
important que l'économie le ministère
l'économie a pas un budget comme cela on
met en qui on en perd plus d'argent dans
ce conte en investi à la lutte aux
changements climatiques
alors définitivement
le troisième poste budgétaire du québec
l'incroyable
csss et statique le lait c'est pour ça
pour ce que c'est tellement intéressant
d'avoir cette conversation là parce que
moi je te mens tu es
comprenait pas cette idée la dette c'est
comme la richesse ou si quelqu'un veut
dire
donc te regarde quelqu'un petit jeu
c'est quoi ces richesses une maison où
il y faut cesser ces bretons d'euros qui
s'est déchiré extra-plates du crime mais
foot regarde son passif ou aussi actif
passif
excitant un million d'actifs paix
millions de passif net c zéro paribas 0
puis pour donner un ordre de grandeur
nous sommes je me souviens aussi cancon
en 2012 à l'époque et un camp militaire
dans les rues pour la petite histoire
mais semble qu'elles circulent sur un
ring for de la banque nationale vous
étiez non par que l'achat nice
mais semble qu'en dit que c'était comme
si 5 millions closes comme son maxi free
puis à jour
une liste arrêtée à ok oui c'est
intéressant sur ces ça reste un petit
chiffre comparativement à 8 milliards
pour quelque chose de différent
d'abord on a les frais de scolarité les
plus beaux
[Musique]
puis je suis puisque mon garçon
étudiants ontario
au québec
mais vous avez raison c'est c'est
considérable au score mais sa dette puis
l'argent qu'on met le pop d'autres
choses puis la dette c'est pas toujours
négatif le récit mais tant que tu
construis
méthode construite shon mais le temps
une bonne d'être construit l'hôpital
moderne
mais il reste que apprécié au faut que
tu rembourses ladite télépaiement
capitale les paiements d'intérêts
l'argent tu mets là dessus tu là pour
faire d'autre quels sont les livres les
étapes
pour pour arriver à un budget demain à
un
équilibre budgétaire pour arriver au
pire en tranquillement
rembourser cette dette lequel sont les
étapes en place ok mais là je vais te
donner une recherche comptable qui
fonctionne vraiment bien que parfait je
l'utilisais finances
il faut que tu es revenu cross plus vite
que tu n'es pas un
fake mais tente à 100 milliards de
revenus 100 milliards de dépenses
étaient revenus croissent à trous et
demi pour cent par année des dépenses à
tour et tu vas t'en surplus
cité dépenses croissent à 4% des revenus
à tous est souhaitée en deux factions et
on appelle sur les légendes et fois
vulgarise premier appel sur l'efficacité
opérationnelle vous et que tes revenus
croissent plus vite que les dépenses se
c'est vraiment important ouais parce que
peu importe ton point de départ la
situation va s'améliorer clide et ses
potes avec avec cette vision là l'idée
ce n'est pas de couper maintenant mais
c'est de planifier pour une croissance
des ventes se passe tu veux pas faire ce
qu'on appelle des chocs ou du stop and
go budgétaire tu veux pas dire long de
10 milliards de déficit fait concoctant
ils dépensent des milliards mais le ca
marche paul ouais parce que
parce qu'il faut qu'on puisse continuer
à vivre si tous les ajustements qui sont
fait graduellement sont toujours plus
facile à absorber you were
aujourd'hui que les chocs mais c'est une
position je reviens c'est parce que ça
va pas être une position évidente pour
vous d'être celui qui doit dire non tout
le temps parce que des coupes et des
pensées se dire non souvent injustement
pythie tous les deux tous les secteurs
voudrais avoir plus de moyens une fin
que tout le monde qui travaille dans le
secteur s'est dit si j'habite telle
somme de plus pourrait faire si je
préfère ce prêt régler le problème puis
vous vous devez d un nom parce que vous
coupez dépenses mais j'irai que la
partie facile c'est dire non inscrit
dieu c'est travailler pour trouver une
solution qui votent et des mes collègues
une nuit collègue me demande
je reprendrais bien servir la demande 6
milliards sur 5 1 pour lutter contre les
changements climatiques si je dis non
non on le prend l'argent facile ici j on
va voir comment est-ce qu'on peut
t'aider on va regarder montre-moi les 28
chose que tu veux faire selon les
analyses on le regarde d'un point de vue
différent blondy finalement je pense
qu'avec 5 millions au lieu de six puis
22 mesure où le 28 pourrais tu pourrais
avoir autant de réduction de gaz à effet
de serre résultant fait moi je je je je
mène fierté
d'essayer de dire oui mais ouais ok puis
d'essayer d'aider
mes collègues m'ont et 26 aux courses et
les met à réaliser
nos promesses nos ambitions en fermant
sa société avec girex tu dis tout le
temps n'était pas ministre des finances
y ont d'ailleurs c'est l'environnement
bon aussi thèmes à aborder parce que
c'est comme dans tout jeu utilise en
fait j'utilise moustiques mais le mot
que je voulais
que des
décisions qui sont durs à prendre puis
de trouver justement
l'équilibré subtil environnement est un
autre exemple de
en ce moment se noue crise en fait c'est
comme la crise en août à la crise
climatique est peut-être moins
visés mais quand on joue au hockey
pendant 40 ans et pas mal avisée pour
ses livres on la voit
pilot faut trouver des solutions à ceux
qui s'imaginent que ces solutions le
sont pas toujours
fiscalement ou économiquement
logique
mais des fois les impératifs économiques
reda mais des fois si les impératifs
sociaux toujours on essaie d'avoir le
bonnet qui
s'est
par exemple augmenter les dépenses en
éducation
ben ça augmente le déficit mais c'était
une excellente investissement à long
terme alors c'est correct d'augmenter
les dépenses en éducation ce qu'on fait
mais on veut s'assurer que l'argent lui
six points juste de dire ont redonné
plus chargées au sujet on sait qu'il ya
des besoins et ces jeunes mais où on va
mettre l'argent nécessaire
est-ce que de la pandémie au changer les
priorités c'est que soudainement c'est
important que les professeurs et de
l'aide technique pour donner des cours
c'était pour donner des cours à 10 ans
puis les étudiants soudainement c'est la
santé mentale au cégep ce n'est pas le
sujet numéro un
on parle plus d'eux j'ai pas moins de
toxicomanie d'éducation sexuelle dessus
dès demain on s'est rendu compte que
c'est pas tout le monde qui avait des
conditions optimales chez eux pour
étudier le la santé mentale est devenue
importante que l'on a mis des ressources
pour sopi le ministre car demain play
mini smoke and so far so les
cépages us demain d'argent c'est on a un
rôle de fiduciaire faut bien dépenser
l'argent des contribuables
je comprends pour l'économie de
l'éducation que c'est un investissement
mais pour ce qui est de l'environnement
l'argentine est là dedans c'est pas
forcément de l'argent que vous revoir
d'abord il ya des
endroits où il ya eu
ces conjoints ici investis dans
l'économie
l'énergie renouvelable tu fais des
investissements permettant ces bombes
l'environnement s'est investie en
transport en commun si tu prends une
usine et utilise du pétrole pour faire
ces procédés chimiques l'a convertie au
gaz naturel
mais la conversion réduit les gars
y'a moyen de concilier
économie environnement je pense que tout
le monde le reconnaît mais il ya aussi
des coûts
si par exemple si on
augmente les frais d'immatriculation
pour les
grosses cylindrées
si on augmente les permis pour conduire
des camions que ce terreau balayé les
coups puis ses bons plans c'est
justement là
la taxation sur ces choses là ne tombe
pour
pisser dessus une avenue possible dans
le futur au québec tu le sais nous au
québec on est champion de la taxation
il fait que si c'était ça le secret on
avait gagné la coupe
on ne règle rien que parce que
on les champions de la taxation aucun
fardeau fiscal
faites cesser
oui on peut utiliser des modifications
du prix relatif pour modifier les
comportements si tu montes le prix de
certaines cigarettes les gens vont moins
floue et le prix ça
l'impact l'impact
c'est une option
ça fait partie de toutes les options
mieux mais dans l'ensemble nous notre
maman on a réduit le fardeau fiscal de
deux milliards par année
on veut continuer parce que les gens qui
les gens lorsqu'ils garde plus de leur
revenu sur 10000 dans leur pays 13 5000
d'alors mais c'est bien messi pouvait en
rester 7500 c'est encore mieux avec nous
on veut on veut pas augmenter le fardeau
fiscal qatar aurait diminué parce que
les gens sont des jeux énormément taxé
pique quand je vais au marché public
soler la mesure que les gens parlent le
plus les gens me dit sport merci d'avoir
bâti taxe scolaire pire merci les
allocations famille ou à il le crédit
d'impôt maintien des messieurs j'aime
sur les gens partout les gens pas
présente des frais de stationnement les
options caisse où les gens sont vraiment
content parce qu'on a mis une limite 10
dollars par jour pas plus les gens sont
par auteur le voir plus clair mind quand
quelqu'un de ma
famille soient les pirates rivaux quant
à couches t'as pas besoin payer en plus
d'un dollar par jour 200 céline que ces
mesures et du giro du fardeau fiscal ou
sens large les gens apprécient une autre
une autre forme
que je veux qu'on discute parce qu'il
ne doit pas être le seul à trouver ce
dont on parle beaucoup de
dons nous justement le tilleul et le
parking diminuer puis on est content ou
une taxe qui montrent bien on est on est
fâché ou un moment clé pour 200 pi et
après ça arrive en affaires comme les
ipp en europe apple qui sont souvent
aussi avec l'évasion fiscale alpi c'est
difficile en tant que connaître citoyens
de la classe moyenne de la classe
moyenne de trouver que toutes ces
mesures là qui nous sont qui nous sont
imposées que ce soit et que ce soit
positif ou négatif ont un réel impact
quand on voit tout ce qui s'en vont tous
qui disparaît tout ce qui tout l'argent
qui est perdu dans ses pensées paradis
fiscaux le puits dans des dans des
dossiers comme ça
fait comment qu'on fait pour
lutter contre ça comment qu'on fait pour
ce pur pour qu'une qu'on a l'impression
que tout le monde fait sa juste part
puis qu'on ne sait pas nous tout le
temps qui est en train de faire des
choses note sur note notre argent
durement gagné mais qui au final on a
l'impression qu'ils salle aucun impact
quand quelqu'un qu'on entend les
chiffres qui
mais c'est ce que plus l'assiette
fiscale et l'âge - chacun des membres
vont payer un fardeau élevé ok donc le
point vous dites c'est extrêmement
important que tout le monde paie sa
juste part pour ce qui dépend du
panama peur mon analyse toutes les
listes avec l'agencé de revenu du canada
je vous dirais que malheureusement ces
poteaux qui nous a donné sa peau était
un filon une source de revenus
supplémentaires pour revenu québec
l'agent ce dirt musquin deux énormes
mais les listes à la pointe de l'iceberg
si on lit ça n'arrive à mais on a mis
des progrès premièrement de plus de
ressources on a rajouté on a à peu près
cent soixante-trois personnes chez
revenu québec qui lutte à l'évasion
fiscale
on a fait des divulgations volontaires
on a dit aux gens si vos enfants sont
pas trop
parce qu'il ya des zones grises s'il ya
l'évasion fiscale puis à l'évitement
fiscal nains qui enfreint des lois lancé
jouer avec les jouets la marge qui est
gratuit ce qu'on en fait c'est légal
mais c'est à dire que toll droit d'un
président d'un autre pays
si tu joues tennis tu décides que ta
résidence et les baromètres paie plein
pot au québec mais si tu gagnes de
l'argent au québec puis tu le transfert
d'une manière dans une orque labo à ce
moment là tu est exposé de déclarer des
revenus à l'étranger puis en haute idée
que leur peau à cause du secret bancaire
lorsqu on a fait ce qu'on a forcé des
divulgations on ai dit vous avez jusqu à
telle période pour divulguer vous
revenus à l'étranger d'emblée sur les
divulgations volontaires puis en échange
de divulgation volontaire
pas de pénalités pote poursuite mais des
revenus saas etc ah ça c'est fait ça
c'est fait ça a commencé avec le
ministre des finances précédent une
commission des finances publiques et ont
fait des gestes on était au pouvoir on a
rajouté des ressources on a augmenté la
collaboration avec l'agencé de revenu du
canada parce que l'international sekana
donne le joueur clé la collaboration est
excellente on récolte à peu près 500
millions par année dans la lutte à
l'évasion fiscale apprécier ce que
j'appellerai les diffusent gaz les
divulgations non volontaire et nous
posent des questions de planification
fiscale abusive
l'évitement quai puis là on les connaît
nous contribuables on est huit millions
et demi le 1 % au québec c'est quand
qu'on parle du 1% on pense
à bill gates
au québec
le 1 % et commença à 220 trop y croire
épilogue 1% pays 19 % des impôts
tout de suite là on les connaît on
contribue à un billion knees étudie les
déclarations puis fait qu on a fait des
progrès énormes on va en faire en compte
le québec fait bien dans ce sens là
qu'ont été les premiers à imposer la tvq
sur les lits services numériques comme
netflix
amazon est
fake c'est pas parfait
on s'en occupe faut travailler en
collaboration que l' agence du revenu du
canada avec les étalons va amener
l'impôt minimum sur les corporations 15%
d impôt minimum sur les corporations ce
sabbat idée aussi fait que
dit on a tout notre responsabilité au
site il ya
c'est ce que parler des pans d'europe et
c'est chacun faut savoir aussi qu'il y
ait de l'évitement il ya de l'évasion
fiscale qui se fait aussi en
construction résidentielle les gens
payent leurs interventions cash qu'une
demande pas de facture le ils payent pas
de tvq mais pas de tps
bon il ya des inconvénients si lyon doit
de garantie etc mais il reste dans la
construction résidentielle haut c'est
qu'on peut faire mieux est ce qu on sait
à peu près on est capable d'estimer
combien d'argent et est perdu dans la
rénovation ou la construction
résidentielle capable d'estimer la
réponse est oui mon di rupo
mais bref ce que vous ne dites c'est
qu'est finalement
l'idée qu'on se fait que des milliards
de dollars qui sont
jamais perçu par les troupes qui sont
jamais utilisées pour nous tous
c'est pas exactement c'est pas un si
gros problème que ce n'est pas des mieux
on travaille là dessus quand je vous dis
on était à peu près 400 à 500 millions
d'années est ce qu'on va pour se rendre
à chiens oui on s'est entendu que le
fédéral tps tvq sur tous les biens
étrangers parce qu'avant on avait juste
les services sont un pôle et bien c'est
fait et livre un colis se faisait livrer
un colis de nike ios et ne paient pas de
tvq nike points seuil au-dessus paya tvq
dans le corriger ce qui fait deja fait
donc maintenant les biens étrangers ou
les biens domestiques sont sur un pied
d'égalité avec ça c'est réglé
il ya des corporations qui payent pas
d'impôts non vient de s'entendre
l'international parce qu'ils déplacent
des revenus dans les juridictions à
fiscalité réduite
maintenant une compagnie canadienne mais
une filiale en irlande clos des profits
au canada mais tu payes ta filiales en
irlande pour faire des travaux puis le
mot mais l'on vient de s'entendre à
l'international avoir un impôt minimum
partout dans le monde 15 % enfin quand
on fait des progrès
justement tu te retrouves parler de
netflix pim
qui perçoivent le tps tvq c't'un gars
n'en font soudain nouvelle sauf que ça
reste que ces consommateurs qu'ils
payent le plus tripoli c'est pas nous
explique ce qu'il paie mais le tout lui
d'expliquer
quelque chose d'extrêmement important
parce que dans des baux le taxent net
repli les gens pensaient que ça netflix
bay alex segura
mepi netflix quand je vois ce mélange il
aperçoit puis l'anversois de l'armée
gouvernement mais puisqu'elle va
soumettre en mai netflix paie pas
d'impôt au québec canada
les le pied si quelqu'un me demande est
ce que lui paye l'impôt je le dirai pôle
télé la situation fiscale des
entreprises des individus c'est
confidentiel je comprends ok mais
le but c'est que tout le monde paye
c'est juste parfait s'ils ont des
revenus au canada
qui payent pas d'impôt qu'un ado c'est
ce qu'on est en train de regarder ce
qu'est
qui mais je parle pas je peux dire
netflix et comme équipier spécialement
les autres mais selon la loi même steen
une entreprise américaine cit fait des
revenus qui en a deux qui doit payer
l'impôt car c'est ce que c'est
réellement les peaux des corporations
c'est le ski est important c'est
l'établissement stable si les revenus
sont faits à partir des états unis 6 et
netflix usc qui vend le produit au
canada y a pas d'impôt licapa si nous on
est abonné à naître flexion et c'est
l'homme et nat pour payer la tvq mais
netflix propos d'impôts les corporations
le
passé l'étape et picamoles pour les
particuliers ces lieux de je
comprends mais tu es une entreprise ça
reste quelque chose de matériel non sens
que oui je dis c'est moche basée à telle
place ils le vivent mal maintenant si
c'est global est inutile la vente en
ligne ce très bon pour haïti
je comprends pas pourquoi qu'il le fait
que ce soit basé peu importe où sont
basés si tu fais des revenus canada me
semble qu'il devrait donner son ok mais
par exemple supprimés
le gars fable liant l'entreprise
il ya beaucoup d'étrangers bhl s'est
passé pas une usine qui produit au
canada au port vendres fait
normalement s'il ya une entreprise ou
canada par exemple ubisoft canada ont
payé des impôts canado puis ubisoft
monde paye ses impôts payent et mais
dans les faits
une entreprise amazon canado amazon mon
nid à 10 transferts de fonds des
entreprises sur les prix de transfert
c'est difficile de réconcilier l'impôt
des corporations fait que c'est pour ça
que le lieu de résidence principale le
siège social c'est extrêmement important
c'est pour ça qu'on amène un impôt
minimum c'est pour ça que pour les
grandes entreprises
telles que les gars femmes on s'entend
aussi sur haut niveau le souci extrême
on est dans des sujets complets mais son
secteur on s'entend que
le canada au pouvoir percevoir
des revenus sur les revenus par exemple
de google au canada au même si gougaud
son siège social en france ça c'est la
deuxième partie parce que généralement
la tête on est vraiment dans une qualité
mais la taxe de vente s'est basé sur
l'endroit où il ya la transaction donc
tu consommes peu importe l'origine la
compagnie tu paye des taxes de
consommation mais l'impôt des
corporations s'est basée sur
l'établissement stab concept de
résidence siège social principal
l'eau
pour les grandes multinationales les
gars femmes on va appliquer le principe
de lait des taxes à la consommation sur
l'imposture l'élaboration de tout
compris ben c'est ça me semble la
solution ça me semble un
pays peut-il ces entreprises se sont
concentrées
aux états unis un pied en europe
c'est quand il
y en a donné comme 3% de l'économie
mondiale faction s'agite tout seul bon
il faut faire ce faux face aux personnes
nous écoute mais si tous les pays
s'entendent mais on doit pas être les
seuls à
trouver ban ki moon bay à vouloir c'est
pour ça qu'il faut s'allier avec
l'australie l'angleterre
faut faire des coalitions mais les
américaines la chine l'allemagne plus
ton pot économique est élevé
c'est pas une personne un matelas
un économiste
les américains et chinois ont plus
d'importance que le canada comme la
plupart de ces entreprises sont aux
états unis il faut que les états unis
ils voient leur compte alors l'eau salée
si on leur enlève des revenus de leur
côté mais ça n'arrive pas de revenus de
cellules est là clipse pour ça qu'on a
réussi à s'entendre parce que
probablement jouanno mais je ne le pense
pas qu'ils vont probablement qu'à paul
payer pour 15 % d'impôts aux états unis
probable fait l'eau avec la réforme ils
vont s'y perd 15% partout mais
mondial avec les longs textes de c'est
peut-être pas nécessaire de transférer
des fonds interpays dans les
juridictions à fiscalité réduite
finalement états unis bien que c'est eux
qui ont six entreprises vont avoir plus
de revenus c'est quand même complexe
tout soit et puis moi je profite ce cas
les sens pour ce refus de l'hommisme un
séjour de 6 jours de 16 heures ces
nuances le camp vient le temps de ces
gestes justes nous on a une on a une
plateforme pour les gens qui veulent
encourager le podcast qui s'appelle
battre et on sait comme on ne peut pas
tromper tout le monde paye trois pièces
par mois pour avoir accès à une coupe
d'afrique ont fait fi au début qu'un
côté on est happé c'est peut-être le
2eme mi clos début on a lancé ce plan
tout le monde ils s'abonnent puis comme
pas de nouvelles de pentax lance t il
payer quatre pièces même au début de
mars au à 3 puis au début c'est ios
pleut dans le temps mais c'est quand
même voici tel formulaire que je regarde
d'abord dire les lettres de ce
formulaire là qu'il faut que vous
remplissiez pour pour qu'après sûr vous
abonner doivent-elles doivent donner une
taxe dentelle place qui peut être permis
à tal afar pleut toute la
machine est ce que quand tu commences
une compagnie thé ou au début tu es
moins bien organisé puisque pour ce que
l'on lui québec et un rôle de conseiller
oui ils vont de l'eau foot face dit il
faut que tu tapes écouter des
cotisations sa masse salariale ont
peut-être et qui peut aider à faire ton
sur 2 p puis à presse au camp top plus
de revenus qu'un seul but la faute
commence à charger la tvq les psp
e-1000 québec et puis j'ai eu plus que
j'écoutais l'excellent pas de casse avec
sophie brochu mai à 10h hydro québec
c'est la seule entreprise qui est tous
les québécois mais revenu québec aussi
quand même pas mal de la 6.5 millions
[Rires]
conserver sa cliente et
là je vois je vois le budget 2021-2022
de ce budget le com de com de point
click transfer maintenant
ok ce qui me rend fier c'est que c'était
mon 3e puis je pense c'est celui qu'on a
mieux réussi à simplifier ce à quoi le
plan de match et le plan de match et un
deux trois quatre vingts que la pandémie
en 2021 on fait un qe2 retrouver le
plein emploi en 2022 parce qu'on sait
que on a toujours cent mille personnes
qui travaillent en février 2020 travail
pour présenter
les personnes qui
travaillaient quand partie des emplois
dans quel sens mais personne à moins
qu'ils travaillent soient toutes les
mains non je me mets il ya cent mille
personnes de moins d'emplois aujourd'hui
qu'en février et fait un vin et la
pandémie de
retrouver le plein emploi tours a
retrouvé la trajectoire du plein
potentiel économique avec au dos et
loctudy hockey us à l'économie c'est que
le québec
s'analyse bon talent et qu'il est
budgétaire ont tout plein emploi le taux
de chômage d'académie pour ça les
revenus vont bien on s'envoie une
trajectoire on croit les trois dernières
années
2007-2008-2009 croissance moyen à peu
près 2% un peu plus nos cerveaux comme
ceux là rig le choc
l'os assez
2020-2021 rebondi
mais
on en 2020 et 2021 puis lors 2021 on est
revenus ou en étant 2020 mais on a perdu
la croissance de ce qu'elles ont fait ça
ont fait sur le faut reprendre cette
trajectoire essaie de rattraper la
courbe projet d'ici 2025 mais je pense
qu'on va faire mieux comme plein emploi
2022 il ya des chances qu'on le fasse au
début de 2022 plutôt café puis
finalement 4 retrouver l'équilibré
budgétaire en sept ans c'est un
engagement après contribution au fonds
des générations parce que notre
définition de kylie budgétaire nous
sérum et à chaque lorsqu'on était à
l'équilibré au maître côté trop à 4
milliards par année pour les dépenses à
long terme il dépense en capital que
notion comptable revenus dépenses
d'opération dépenses de capitalisation
mais
retrouver l'équilibré budgétaire en
cette 1ère
pandémie deux pleines en point trop
plein de croissance économique car
équilibre aujourd'hui
points 2 parce que
en ce moment justement il veut retrouver
un emploi meilleur ou si en même temps
par allemand zew pénurie de comment
qu'on m'explique ce phénomène mais on
l'expliqué d'abord c'est que il ya eu un
choc économique
le segment de la friction statique au
même moment où on a des demandes en
emploi on veut plus d'infirmières plus
d'enseignants plus de programmeurs parce
qu'elle était télétravail à distance les
colonies ont besoin de plus de monde en
technologies d'information ont besoin de
plus de psychologues au même moment tout
les gens tourisme restauration les
placiers au centre bell les gens
travaillent en interne ont perdu leur
job fait là où même moment où tu as déjà
en chômage tu as des postes vacants mais
les compétences de requises pour ces
gens là sont pas les mamans
[Musique]
un
barman peut devenir préposés aux
bénéficiaires avec une formation de six
mois mais pour devenir infirmier ans à
prendre
pour devenir enseignant ça prend un bac
bon si tu avais des jeux et bac peut
peut-être faire une maîtrise tout mais
il ya des appariements entre les postes
vacants infligeant compo les aider à
faire le pauvre qualification de la main
d'or il faut aider ces gens mais en gros
ce qui nous manque c'est quoi ces des
enseignants des infirmières on parle
beaucoup des services essentiels dans
cet incident il nous manque des
infirmières des psychologues des
orthopédagogues des enseignants des
inhalothérapeutes
il manque du personnel services de garde
mais il manque aussi des programmes en
europe ait
des gens intelligents sortie ciellement
guy genty
alors beaucoup génie ti sur l'essentiel
beaucoup des formations universitaires à
la téléformation oui mais en même temps
les
restaurateurs les stations service sont
amusés à embaucher des gens au salaire
minimum parce que les étudiants
pendant un bout de temps les étudiants
faisait plus d'argent pendant polémique
qui travaillent
donc les programmes qui était valable
les programmes y ont aidé le lier des
jeunes qui ont perdu leurs emplois
répartis et est un appartement de deux
enfants pitt et être plus d'emplois fait
que les programmes sont bons le
mais à mesure que le faire dix-huit mois
plus content pandémie
il faut que les programmes soient sauvés
repeat les gens retournent sur marchera
parce que moi mettons là c'est la
pénurie de main-d'oeuvre mesure
gelé juste remarqué dans les services
comme seul le tir dans les services de
restauration pour touristes parce que
moi je ne vois pas d'anti j'ai pas de
jeu pas en contact avec le manque de
personnel infirmier mais c'est mai
puis ça ça va revenir dans le font
normalement mais en fait
l'objet dans mon domaine favori qui fait
la vision d'économie alors vers l'asie
hockey au québec il ya 7 millions de
personnes de plus de 15 on nous dit que
c'est pour travailler ça prend au moins
pays de ses sept millions de personnes
lors il y en a quatre millions et demi
qui veulent travailler soit qui
travaillent où ils cherchent un job qui
met à en vrai on est à peu près
4.25 qui travaillent puis 250 milles qui
cherchent un job
4.5 millions de personnes qui
travaillent sur 7 millions
potentiellement bon dans 7 millions il
ya des gens qui ont plus de 115 à la
loupe il s'est peut-être c'est normal
qu'ils travaillent pas au fait qu'il
faut les enlever mais le choix je vois
simplifie joie les comptes et ça sinon
ces gens là c'est ici c'est quoi ces
dirigeants veulent d'abord il ya deux
cent mille jeunes c'est important parce
que je pense que les jeunes c'est
pourtant un ok
si je fais le
l'échantillon notamment de missiles
il ya deux cent mille jeunes qui sont ni
en emploi ni aux études ni en formation
seul il faut s'occuper de chacun d'eux
personnellement faut aller les voir
comprendre la réalité pourquoi t'es pas
aller à l'école pourquoi tu vois pas
travailler
comment je peux télé ça c'est le rôle et
carrefour jeunesse emploi mais c'est
aussi le rôle de 2 des écoles
secondaires pour adultes c'est aussi le
rôle des cégeps pourquoi tu as commencé
ton ces jeunes talents chez ton ces
jeunes
puis là on ne trace de tous
enfin ces deux sens mais les jeunes l'os
extrêmement importante de 100000 six
mois après soit mon premier texte une
tragédie c'est que ces gens dehors
sûrement qui veulent travailler il ya
des raisons coûte quelque chose d'autre
info lise et
ensuite temps on pense qu'il ya cent
mille personnes deux sont dix mille
personnes de plus de 60 ans qui devrait
travailler son avait le même taux de
participation de l'ontario acfo
comprendre est ce que c'est une question
de culture est ce que c'est parce que
les entreprises aient mieux avoir des
impôts y quarante ans que les employés
de 60 de
discrimination est ce que c'est parce
que
les gens à 62 ans présente veulent pas
travailler saint-jo semaine ce que je
joue au golf 5 jours/semaine l'énergie
sport c'est plate pour garder deux jours
par semaine c'est l'fun
mais peut-être que tu veux travailler
deux jours
proposé une journée vous gave de jours
et qu'il ya peut-être que ça prend deux
personnes de plus de 60 ans de faire la
job qu'une personne de 40 ans cela il ya
un champ dix mille personnes droit il ya
deux cent mille personnes qui
travaillent en février qui travaille
pour qu'il dise à paris avec les dom moi
ce que je voulais vous dire avec michif
le mot 4.5 millions pour 7 millions
c'est que si le 4.5 millions à 5
millions on a là aucun problème
il faut augmenter la participation au
marché du travail faut encourager les
gens à travailler pour ça ça prend des
garderies parce que peut-être qu'il ya
une infirmière etc ce dimanche vous
allez travailler j'ai pas dire des
folies dans une place en garderie mon
collègue travaille là dessus et tout le
gouvernement
mais si on avait cinq millions de
personnes qui veulent travailler ou les
4.5 ben on comblerait les deux cent
mille postes vacants on aurait une
friction ou le fait qu'il ya des postes
d'ingénieurs pour la même formation que
qu'un plat si
dernière show coin c'est que vous
encourager gens travailler avec foulards
le feu aux abords des cours de formation
faut les payer pour qu'ils prennent leur
formation des sites wallons tout d'un
coup ça tente de faire un cours une
technique un service de guerre
électronique mais ne fauche t'encourage
de luminaires pendant tout prend des
coups je paye ton coup je te paye
pendant qu'il prend 2 le ministre boulet
ministre ait un peu chaque film ils
réservent des formations ils payent pour
supplanta formation ça c'est bon l'autre
chose c'est ce que si au lieu quand tu
travailles 10 dollars il tresse 7
dollars mais si tu travailles et site
restait sept de leurs ennemis peut-être
travailler une heure de plus de trois
heures c'est ce que les gens tu payes
ton épicerie en revenus nets là tu payes
pas ton épicerie un revenu brut fait
l'impôt est important c'est ce que le
prix de la rémunération de travail c'est
plus élevée les gens travaillent tous
puis les recherches 1 100 milles travail
c'est sa faculté c'est que les
travailleurs sont déjà ici
mais l'immigration se fait par
la fusion des migrations société est
extrêmement possible parce que les la
population du québec est vieillissant le
profil des immigrés plus jeunes les
immigrants de première génération
travaille très fort les enfants de ces
immigrants lourds sont souvent plus que
l'alizé puis
on voit que les la situation économique
1000 nouveaux arrivants est moins bonne
que lilo coup mais que souvent dès la
deuxième génération où les cas mais au
delà de l'économie dont la contribution
à ce site et les immigrés extrêmement
possible l'immigration se fait par cette
session mais mais pas plus que les deux
champions
et une news emploi mais ya moins d'une
migration ici qu'à tantôt pas croire
qu'on était plutôt être qu'on devrait en
accueillir plus mais c'est à dire que
nous on a baissé de 50 2000 à 40 milles
pour recommencer augmenté 40 44 48 52
l'on n'ait rendu 49 52 mais parra n'est
plus ce qu'on ne pas cueillir raisons
qui fondent certains ferment 2000
maillots fait de rattrapage il y en a
marre acquis 25 on en a fait 8000 de
plus l'année 2002 puissant prochain il
faudra pas chômé
c'est en fonction de la capacité
d'intégration parce que vu qu'on est la
seule société francophone en amérique du
nord mais il faut pas
déterminé le nombre d'immigrants en
fonction de combien on en a besoin pour
le marché us rail fo faut être conscient
de notre capacité d'intégration fait
faut maximiser notre nombre d'immigrants
sous contrainte de notre capacité à les
intégrer reconnaître leur diplôme les
aider à se franciser les aider à se
loger
puis encore l'eau ou un autre phénomène
aussi c'est que les migrants viennent à
mon rien parce que les communautés
d'accueil puis on a dit rareté de
main-d'oeuvre entre autres dans les
régions qui les a aidés il y en a des
immigrés gauche tout minot mais c'est
plus passer là lâche tout chimique à mon
arrivée
je me rappelle à l'école primaire y
avait une égyptienne
puis chez les revues
vtt c'est spécial et sortir
s'appelait cour
spéciale
c'était la seule six classes pour la
réalité un moyen aujourd'hui
effectivement que c'est en région
surtout le tuyau d'eau je suis juste
allée regard du loup le wt fermé
toujours mais est ce qu'on a besoin d'un
w
[Musique]
il ya déjà dans lesquelles c'est
quétaine numérique et son nettop
quelques pénuries une rareté de
main-d'oeuvre que moi béton si je me fie
ce que j'entends dans les médias du
moins comme étant infirmière ou
prof le thé profondément second devra
maintenant
ça c'est pas mon premier choix
maintenant parce qu'ils aient salaire de
ce qu'on a entendu - les conditions de
travail on l'a extrêmement difficile les
charges de travail extrêmement élevé
qu'on fait ainsi de faire beaucoup avec
plus de moyens
comment ce qu'on incite les gens à les
combler c'est parce que quand quelqu'un
qui est que des moins de l'opinion
publique - moi ce que j'observe sa part
arrivé que je te donnais un argument
social pour l'économie et pour lequel
touche le plus
premièrement je pense que foutait la
vocation à enseigner
l'ossétie magnifique tu es en première
année j'en arrive sa police grippe a
n'est lis et relis et puis en juin savez
kris fantastique quand tu prends une
enfant 5e annick et discuter de lecture
celui-là est sûre c'est valorisant
quelqu'un qui programment résoudre des
équations différentielles deuxième à
l'université tulane les oies ou steagall
de vierges tech - fantastique une
valorisant les métiers qui sont
valorisés deuxième argument c'est dit
dans le secteur public les régimes de
retraite sont généreux lors les audi on
parle souvent des conditions de travail
les conditions de travail le monétaire
le monétaire ont un travail mais ma
collègue son hub elle travaille avec eux
pour on le dit on améliore les
conditions
financières de ces travailleurs loin on
fait un rattrapage je sais ce qu'on
tient pour les enseignants puis les
infirmières d'autres
mais aussi il faut se le dire le régime
de retraite à prestations déterminées
garantis par le gouvernement ça existe
cependant privés sauf quand tu
travailles dans le secteur public tout
ce que ça vaut beaucoup ça faisait que
si tu travailles
certain nombre d'années de retraite
garanti par le gouvernement sa motion je
comprends mais je te mens tu les gens
que cette vocation le jeu free spins job
que dans laquelle karabakh en dix ans
genre une belle retraite et qui joue au
jour le jour c'est le court terme mais
l'auteur principal sinon je comprends
mais c'est l'impression qui pipe je
pense j'ai pas l'impression à ce que que
sinon plus une question de sarah j'ai
l'impression que ce soit ce qu'on attend
c'est débordés
trop d'élèves dans les classes trop de
patience occuper trop trop trop le très
difficilement
arrête un saignante
avec des milieux défavorisés c'est
extrêmement difficile
pour ça que fall dit le cge au font un
travail remarquable puis on a besoin
d'eux pour les apprécie
et j'imagine que une des pistes pour que
ça devienne justement - c'est le seul à
avoir plus de monde
nous avons des ratios c'est sûr qu'une
classe de 25 classes de
puissants et patients vers ce suivi de
patients moins la même chose en plus
trois éléments discutés où je serai dans
le temps illimité une contrée
quelque chose que je me demande moi
c'est avec avec juste juste dans ma vie
à moi si on a vu passer des
gouvernements le au québec le plein
différents avec des projets différents
des directions différentes puis tout le
temps l'impression qu'on on recommence
tout le temps à chaque fois que
quelqu'un ait un nouveau gouvernement
est élu on a l'impression qu'on
recommence un projet éthique on
recommence une vision à long terme puis
on parlait tout à l'heure des économies
à long terme tpiy
ggyc j'ai l'impression puis peut-être
que je me trompe peut-être que c'est
juste que je suis mal informée à ce
sujet là mais j'ai l'impression que
on voit pas plus loin que
que par blocs de quatre ans qu'on a de
la misère à
travailler sur une idée qui pourrait
être celle on parle du vieillissement de
la population le vieillissement la
population là c'est la chose la plus
facile à prédire au monde entier le
dessus plus on est comme le
vieillissement la population problèmes
de main d'oeuvre vainquer mais pourquoi
est-ce qu'il n'y avait pas des mesures
de jeu qu'on n'était pas prêt à ce que
ça arrive pourquoi est-ce qu'on a pâti
des jardins
je veux juste savoir c'est quoi c'est
quoi ta vision de ce parce que tu as
l'air de quelqu'un que l'économie à long
terme dans la tête sauf que commencèrent
comment ça s'articule qu'en accueillant
un système ios cas où est-ce qu'il faut
tout le temps revalider à chaque quatre
ans puis ça change beaucoup selon la
personne qui est à la tête d'un parti ou
que ça change selon ti toutes ces
affaires là c'est toujours de marines et
tour depuis chaque partie du toujours
qu'est ce que l'autre fait avant mais on
allait mais d'abord moi j'essaie de pas
être partisane en un mot je suis au pij
suivant mon équipe et il est également
nommé chris je passe souvent
les bonnes choses à long terme c est ce
que tu parles les vulnérabilités du
québec pourquoi la première vague allées
étaient plus dures au québec qu'ailleurs
d'abord parce que notre population est
plus vieille
démographie deuxièmement parce que nos
infrastructures nous aussi à celle du
n'était pas en bon état
et puis nous écoles moins bonne
ventilation d'infrastructures moins
bonne ventilation parce que tu es on
pense les écoles ont dit aux lions pas
des belles cour d'école mais les les
nos infrastructures
sont vieillissantes notre population et
vieillissent alors si un gouvernement ou
un parti qu'aimerait gouvernement promet
d'investir dans l'infrastructure
ça devrait être évident que c'est une
bonne idée parce que tu vois l'état des
routes tu vois que la ligne anglais
plein alors de point d'eau où était
parce que gelée pour marie depuis
cheminé depuis quand en pandémie
mais tu vois nos infrastructures puis
par exemple il ya eu beaucoup moins de
cochon qui est un hôpital moderne caja
maisonneuve rosemont qui est un hôpital
plus vétus et donc moins une capacité
d'isoler patience au fait que
layton aux infrastructures important
lors la population vieillissante mais si
un parti dit nous on voit investi ne
soient les messieurs devraient le oui je
pense que les gens préfèrent vielles
maisons aucun un studio
ces bonnes choses c'est que je pense que
comme citoyen faut s'informer faut voter
tous les partis sont pas pareilles et
puis au fédéral
georges le jour m'avancer mais mon
équipe me
en fin de semaine chez par les gens
parlaient visait justin trudeau je
n'aime pas facile face à face à jeudi
moi j'ai juste répondu par un supporter
un trou d'où le problème ces
alternatives
ces boues du jeu j'aime pas le premier
ministre parce qu'il fait ok
décontraction c'est quoi telle option
est important pour qui tu vois non
municipal la fantastique madame plan
monsieur coderre ni un ni le dicton vote
là niveau il faut qu'elle trouve
vraiment à y voter il faut que je
t'informe puis thil et les gens ont
critiqué la piste de vélo ce n'est ni un
cénotaphe à l'ailé
les infrastructures mais quand tu les
rénove sacré des inconvénients puis les
connards le pas est fait et l'onu ont
sécurisé du tunnel louis hippolyte
lafontaine
mais quand il enfile pour traverser de
finale soit pas content le sac après le
gouvernement
mais ce que je veux dire un moyen c'est
que ces séries les deux candidates votre
votre compte aller voter informez vous
faites votre choix
c'est pour ces deux visions c'est sûr on
devrais je risque d'en mourir
c'est peut-être pas prêt question
c'est je comprends qu on dirait que j'ai
jamais compris pourquoi
pourquoi les gouvernements changer
autant que
puis pourquoi est-ce-que amener ces
libéraux plus long que votre libéraux
mais le rayon mais là l'on voit que la
carte puis pourquoi cesser le parti
québécois mais pourquoi tiens j'ai
jamais compris vraiment pourquoi est-ce
que des votes change c'est d'abord lui
jure et un moment donné les gens
[Musique]
mais ton
juste un exemple stephen harper après
dix ans est ce que monsieur trudeau il
ya gagné l'élection ou se débarrasser de
celui qu'on avait depuis déjà bien
ternie il faut faire attention les
livres le mans change entre autres parce
que les
parce que du jeu mais on stagne ou
baisse que c'est les promesses qui sont
pas remplies ou est ce qu'on sait où
justement est-ce que c'est qu'on laisse
pas assez de temps à un gouvernement
pour mettre en place un projet sur de
longue haleine c'est
parce que moi j'ai l'impression que
c'est souvent ceux souvent justement
l'exemple du tunnel c'est l'exemple du
tunnel louis hippolyte la fontaine où
est ce que le sait à qui un plus gros
projets d'infrastructures de refaire
louis près de la fontaine place et art
sous ce gouvernement là il ya du trafic
devrait de sortir de chez nous fait que
le change mais laissent pas le temps aux
projets de s'accomplir d'arriver vers la
vision que le gouvernement avec ce
projet là moi mais mes témoins
2008 je me suis promené à boub rien aux
masses intérêts on ne fait trop 4000
porte on cogne et bonjour je m'appelle
région je me suis dit du
les gens en parlaient du trafic sa
caisse
c'est vraiment c'est l'os est
bon
pilot moi ma réponse a sausset des voies
réservées il ya personne n'envoie
résorber la voie réservée c'est soit et
en transport en commun soit est en
voiture électrique souhaitait en
couverture et puis la voie réservée au
delà de la 40e on l'a de montréal
jusqu'à 4 qu'un parent le plus
avec moi tu me dis que cette année de sa
fille qu on veut favoriser le tout par
page des transports en commun avec ça ne
prend plus de voies réservées fait nous
on s'est engagé à voir des voies
réservées sur l'a 15 nord qui voit les
oryx se terminer à 4 40 est prolongée
jusqu à 6 40 et prendre jusqu'à cinq
mais là on le dit après ça
c'est bien de la virgule heures c'est ce
qu'il fait et fait clos on l'annoncé on
va le faire on est en marche il ya comme
citoyen je pense que c'est important que
le
husky dit puisqu'il fait moins c'est ce
qu'il faut que tu juges mes livres et
c'est dur c'est maintenant on va des
voies réservées 5 la face que tu veux
pas trop
avoir d'impact sur le trafic existant si
tu mets tes chers fosse 3 voilà le monde
seront pas contents fait la faute du
gers à auch est-ce qu'on peut travailler
sur la fin de semaine est ce qu'on peut
travailler dans le terre-plein pas
affecté voir que toute une planification
plus probablement tu veux pas faire la
15e en même temps que la 13
puis c'est ça peut-être que peut-être
que c'est un manque
de
manque de vision à long terme du projet
de société dans le fond nous sommes et
de vision globale en fait parce que
c'est quelque chose qui t'a fait
personnellement être y est si les
travaux affectant également petite
rallonge pareils c'est ce que le big
picture de 500 pi pour l'ensemble de ce
travail mieux on a toujours ce
qu'entend mener deux objets en fait il y
en a pas on a parlé beaucoup d'un et là
on devrait parler de l'autre les spas
baseball grand fan de baseball à la
bombe magique
puis
des fournisseurs
j'exagère mais pas beaucoup je me
souviens très bien que à tomber chez
qu'aujourd'hui les noms ont changé que
c'est un monde me jouait à tomber je me
suis très bien que j'étais le joie bio
le maul faut pas dire sur ce prochain
t-il jour la plus proche de mon équipe
on peut s'attendre
je n'ai vraiment pas bon ça le
bit à casquette et il met une casquette
lui l'eau pour se protéger ou bibi au
bâton tgap est soigné mon jeu très
mauvais mais j'ai mes sauts puis mon
frère tu es bon puis s'élance avec moi
puis mon patin bon puis il m'a aidé et
puis j'ai fait un cap puis finalement
j'ai joué même temps milité j'ai
persévéré j'ai eu du plaisir
c'est quand tu y mets izard puis moi je
jouais l'après-midi pour le plaisir et
puis on joue écrit philippe nos amis le
bon s'installer puis il y en a qui la
piscine pour jour bessborough le coup de
manche la piscine le soir je vois
compétitif et puis j'ai utilisées c'est
toujours ma soi puis j'ai appris mon à
régler on écoute un lot
puis quand je voyage dans le monde quand
je vais aux états unis et si on voit san
diego mais il y en avait visité des
porte avions où on le visite mais on
vous passe pas on va voir les maraudes
répit en 2012 prévoit un marché mondial
ces scènes quand tu suis le baseball
depuis 1972 sages attendue 2012 s'en ira
série mondiale
piste est ce pas le fun je me
rappellerai cette série de quatre matchs
puis le premier je suis arrivé le soir
du premier match et c'est pas le match
que j'allais voir le deuxième nommé mais
je suis arrivé à l'hôtel pierre un
pianiste qu'une casquette desjardins
puis il jouait le tout et musicien je
suis pas qu'elle est tournée les jouets
le mystère endiablé tout le monde
hurlait dans le monde puisque alex goude
jeune
fille le lendemain
je suis allé voir un match les giants
ont grandi de 0.1 maja série mondiale
puis
il y avait un thème l'insee kim qui
avait cheveux longs je peux se
connaissent et se font la bise bat pour
garder la coupe tomlin sikkim un mois
j'ai perdu des chevrets savoir la coupe
à tout le monde tout le monde à san
francisco avait un couple chacun
puis dix mots mais moi j'ai fait du
sport mes enfants on fait du sport ma
fille joue à qui mon gars vous rock et
puis là le match fini je prends je
m'envoie à l'aéroport à san francisco et
je vois là une heure du matin
j'atterris à québec à sa part le matin
tupac et montparnasse à l'aéroport on
s'en vont au mont sainte envoie mon fils
jouer
au hockey 2-3 magique en main en 24h à
100 face coup le monfils joue cellphone
le sport moi je vois ça comme un jeu
mais je suis compétitif un jeu que je
veux gagner
mais
moi j'ai du plaisir quand je tue pas
enfin chez les curés mais je suis
compétitif je vois courait avec ma monde
tchèques montant que la semaine d'après
je fume un parcours puis j'essaie de
faire un peu plus belle qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce que ça t'amène
dans ton quotidien le sport dans ton
travail ça te permet dessus d'eux parce
qu'ici au centre on est des sportifs
dans la langue puis on est des grands
des grand défendeur du support comme
étant une façon de garder ta vie balance
et puis puis de mieux gérer
la vie professionnelle puis la vie
familiale puis tout seul est une balance
oui parce que comme moi je fais du
service public puis une des choses qui
pour facile en politique c'est ce
contrôle pour tourner
ong
comme la personne appelée partant dans
l'équipe sa directrice la jarre de nous
parce qu'elle n'est d'intel est un bol
d'eau par une alerte comme telle
personne ou pile séjourné lot et à
québec ces journées de ta trop violent
le sport c'est le moment où tu peux est
un égoïste heureux c'est juste un pour
toi
quand je vois courir c'est pour moi
quand je joue temps c'est par plaisir
quand je vois en patinoire d'abord je
suis pas tout seul qu'aucun casque je
vous recommande de porter de casque
ménagé pour beaucoup d'influx
j'ai 30 ans plus que le joie moyens
légaux ils me disent pas grand papale
mais il me regarde les défauts sont
gentilles fondé pas
ag la rondelle et
bien non il fait moins 22 puis jean
t-shirt clairement un des gars qui ont
des poussées d'hormones à forte les
miennes joue un t-shirt à -22 2 mais ses
fans dans le jeu j'ai du plaisir
c'est juste que je faucherai conscient
que je me laisse des finances puis il
faut pas charger une commission
habilitée
puis j'ai pas besoin de nouveaux modèles
dans le visage puis des fois impérial
expecting surplus d'air
mais le sport c'est c'est le plaisir
c'est du temps pour toi
timimi meilleurs amis et mes fans de
tennis
si
le gouvernement était une équipe de haut
qui mettront la finance les nordiques de
québec
position dans l'équipe attend
même au hockey
jetez un compteur
c'est à dire que parce qu'après
brouettée go leurs moyens
je suis devenu joueur puis ma spécialité
c'est être contribuer tout avec patrick
roy
jusqu'au bout ils cherchent dans son
livre grâce à son livre une photo le
écoles de sainte foy top patrick que
toute sa carrure que tu vois que c'est
un pro
c'est moi
c'est
les vu une fois au centre de chevet et
patrick merci d'avoir mieux ma foi tout
noir dans les morgan
c'est qui lui
[Rires]
au magasin
a placé une fois
la question c'est quoi la gaston ses
séquelles dans un evenemment sais quelle
position mais des finances du goût là où
c'est le marquage ce n'est leur bureau
qui jette un marquage au baseball un
voire deux chiens à mais le gouvernement
s'y succèdent unique il faut que tous
les joueurs de l'équipe travaille bien
vu comment une bande crochet fermé
l'écart de richesse avec la moyenne
canadienne où l'ontario puis livrer des
services de qualité aux citoyens lutter
contre le réchauffement climatique fait
que nous nos objectifs sont clairs
l'équipe tous les éléments moi ce qui me
fait le plus plaisir c'est quand les
gens disent wow
lionel carmant vraiment du bol parce
qu'une miel clairement c'est le ministre
des services sociaux si les gens
apprécient lionel carmant c'est parce
que non seulement il s'est amélioré
personnellement mais c'est parce que ce
qui fait ce terrain le triste un
neurologue
spécialiste du développement de
l'enfance donc si une personne qui est
équipée pour faire une différence avec
moi
moi je peux je peux le dire je donne 100
millions de la santé mentale mais moi je
programme libre il
serait le président le vice-président
qui s'occupe des contrôles
c'est ce qu'on respecte le plafond
salarial ans
dernière question avant de déterminer ce
qu'on dit déjà fait 12 ans on n'a pas
fait de rome
son approche contre
mais
qu'est-ce qu'on fait que le canadien de
montréal
demain qu'on sort de ce
nom je veux dire non mais parce que il
ya
au tampon l'année passée il ya une
anomalie qui fait qu'on a qu'on a évité
un con c'est fermé les yeux sur un
changement comme un peu la copie de sa
lance une trajectoire n'a pas tu sais
pas c'est que l'on d'abord il faut je
pense faut faire confiance aux gens qui
sont en place et du chat ou bergevin
france margaret bélanger cg lol et ses
autres petits morceaux mais
moins jeunes québec j'aime les joueurs
francophones moment gardien favori c'est
jonathan bernier pas parce que c'est le
meilleur parce que je suis sa carrière
depuis longtemps je veux qu'il fasse
bien hier je voulais quelqu'un viande
pour samuel montambault parce que le
goya 25
il ya pas joué beaucoup dans l'hymne
national mais c'est un bon goal un bon
golfeur québécois hier j'aurais aimé ça
ok quinzaine pour samuel montant bout
puis je conteste annick on a plus de
québécois un pérou
droit ça va
c'est une tradition t
c'est dur de perdre de wever price
mon impôt prévues par la loi et que moi
je fais confiance aux gens qui sont en
place puis j'espère que les gens font
confiance aux gens qui sont en place et
au gouvernement de lui mais moi à chaque
jour je me lève puis c'est l'intérêt
supérieur du québec j'essaie de prendre
les meilleures décisions à long terme
pour l'ensemble des québécois
merci beaucoup comme celles accordées ce
temps là merci beaucoup
du contenu excellente à tout un podcast
combien
oui
si vous voulez plus de contenu excellent
comme ce que vous venez d'entendre aller
sur une pétillante répétions vous
abonner pour trop dollars par mois c'est
trop de longs mois et trois pièces par
morlaàs par mois et vous avez les pas de
carte en avance acquise avec les
premiers de votre groupe d'amis avoir
quitté les podcasts puisse avoir pour
avoir une avance quand vous à l'étude de
la dynamique entre les amys tout le
temps avons une avance sur les jobs en
avance ou des centres de toi mais avec
pétillante une avance sur l'humanité
complète en plus en plus parce que le
chèque le podcast unis voulaient nous
entendu davantage on fait des encore
moins de filtres à préchac podcast avec
là on vient de finir de tourner le
podcast on vend josé on va chill et
nicole non nicolas hulot maintenant
comme un fils travaille à place de taza
taille est là mais on jason par la
conversion qu'on m'aide à voir mais ce
si vous voulez avoir accès
mais heureusement pour nous
malheureusement pour vous c'est exclusif
sur têtu il faut s'abonner abonnez vous